getting to Mars will be risky dangerous
but it will be the greatest adventure
ever ever in human history
funny thing about Mars it feels like
Earth but it is more hostile to life at
any place on earth
ignition in the absence of gravity lots
of things can go wrong it's an unknown
and you're basically allowing yourself
to be an experiment
landing hazards for an app chest fire
the question is will you be able to
survive during this crucial time of
arrival
these people are putting their bodies at
risk for us for the human race when we
get to Mars we need protection from
radiation we use of drones to find a
lava tube with the conditions we need to
deploy a small domed habitat and that
little foothold will become humankind's
first real home be under gravity well
well understand if I push this
modification any farther we risk
overloading the entire electrical system
we don't have a choice
what are you doing
if the topography is right and the ice
is there we can justify deployment I
hope you're not scared of the dark
if there was water on Mars couldn't
there possibly be life-size medical lab
is now operational the greenhouse is
complete we at MMC feel that we're ready
to go faster Phase two expansion will be
overseen by the very best our dream is
now a reality they don't know where's my
guys up for welcoming sweaty face
commander Madison
well in two months we'll have enough
power to double the size and capacity of
your facilities it's a little too
ambitious right now you don't go to Mars
with that ambition I don't think we're
gonna get a chance to get that reactor
back online if you've got a dust storm
that lasted for a month you'd be in big
trouble this stone has been raging for
months they call it a season I can't do
my job who is going to have a real
problem in space ultimately there are
some people who are gonna have a really
hard time the storm is getting to
everyone
are you missing home I'm okay he lives
for his work and he can't do it darling
this Paul Richardson does he do
as we buried our friends the fate of the
mission was back on earth
if you send astronauts to Mars and they
die their public opinion will prohibit
you from ever doing it again it's a dumb
to be strong because death alone that
says we're here to stay seven of the
world's most beloved scientists and
astronauts are dead
you're not going to influence my
recommendation to the committee when we
thought he could only get darker there
was light we have been talking about
life on Mars for ever looks like I never
liked crystal have you hadn't I found
something just think about what it would
mean if you found a single-cell
microorganism today marks the end of an
era in the beginning of a new one it
would be so exciting to wake up in the
morning and think that that's that's
what's happening there is life on Mars
[Music]
[Music]
you